attention concentre-toi oh je la connais
moi
je préparer la gâchette
[Musique]
attention deuxième candidat c'est
Valérie Benaim
toujours il y a toujours le mot oh
dedans il y a toujours le monde
c'était quoi le titre
[Musique]
celui qui tire
est éliminé à vie pour tous les jeux de
TPMP et du site et je dis bien radié à
vie il devra rendre sa carte et son
badge
et son insigne il ne sera plus jamais
son abonnement quantique merci tu es
mouillé en tout cas on adore ce jeu
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'aperçois
comme un de ta fenêtre
mais personne ne réponds c'est juste un
signe pour montrer que t'es là
je crie ton nom mais personne ne
m'entend jusqu'à si il suffira laisse la
terre regarde qui est là
un classique attention
c'est bien passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dedans
et pourquoi pas
[Musique]
Céline Dion c'est quoi Céline Dion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et croire en
nemis
[Musique]
Géraldine c'est à toi on va se faire un
petit peu dedans
[Musique]
attention
ça va être carrément c'est ma jeunesse
[Musique]
tiens quand c'est fini c'est fini prenez
allez donne-moi arrête de les remplir
arrête de le remplir quand il y en a
plus il y en a plus merci
allez-y attention
parce que j'aime beaucoup mon tissu
ça va il est bien prenez-la
dernière rempli
[Applaudissements]
Gilles Verdez
les mecs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en direct